There are wounds that don't make any noise, they
don't arrive like a slammed door or
like an argument you
tell your friends over
coffee.
they slowly arrive inside the house, in the place where
you should have felt protected.
Sometimes they have the voice of a father who
belittles everything you do, of a
mother who turns guilt into
a leash, of a brother who knows
exactly where to hit you to make you
doubt yourself.  And this is where
one of the most difficult questions arises,
even for believers.  If family is
sacred, then why is it that sometimes
the soul is consumed there?  I
have a clear answer, because not everything
that is familiar is also
spiritually healthy, and the Bible, if you
read it without romanticism, never asks you
to stay where you are being destroyed.
Many grew up with an almost
untouchable idea of ​​blood ties, very
Italian, very ours.  She's still your
mother, she's still your brother.  The
family is not abandoned.  Phrases
you know well because we hear them
at Sunday lunches, in
small kitchens filled with smells and sauces, in
living rooms where everyone knows everything about everyone else,
but no one mentions the real problem.
Yet [music]
writing does not idolize blood, it
puts truth at the center.
Jesus himself in the Gospel breaks down
emotional hypocrisy when he says that
whoever loves father or mother more than the truth
is not worthy of following him.
It's a shocking phrase because it
undermines the sentimental education with which
many have been trained.
But the point is very clear.  God does not
bless the bonds that distance you
from your dignity, even if they have the
same last name as you.  The first way God
distances you from toxic people
is often not external, but internal.  Even before
changing your circumstances, change
your stomach, your sleep, your
peace.  You begin to feel a heaviness before
a phone call, a strange tiredness
after a visit, a confusion that
arrives punctually after certain
conversations.
There is a call for all this
excessive sensitivity.  I think instead that very
often [music] is discernment.
In the Bible, peace is not just a
sweet emotion, it is also a
spiritual criterion.
When a relationship constantly drains you,
systematically humiliates you,
forces you to cheat just to maintain
a seemingly peaceful truce, you're not facing
a cross to bear, you're facing
a dynamic to acknowledge.  And yes, I
say this with conviction, many believers
call love what is actually
dependence disguised as duty.  Then
something subtle but decisive happens.  God
[music] begins to make you see what you
used to justify.
You realize that you haven't been too
resentful, you've been trained to
tolerate too much.  You realize that that
joke wasn't irony, but
well-packaged contempt.
that what I say for your own good was
control, that the constant reminder of
the sacrifices made for you was not
affection, it was emotional debt.  In Proverbs
we read that above all things we must
guard our heart because from it flows
life.   It does
n't say to offer it to just anyone, it doesn't
say to leave it open to those who
trample on it, it doesn't say to sacrifice your
mental health so as not to disappoint those who
manipulate you.  Guarding your heart sometimes
means closing a door with pain
but without hatred.  Another way God
separates you is that He stops you from
functioning in your old roles.
The peacemaker of the family, the
son who always understands, the one who
absorbs tensions to avoid explosions,
the one [music] who fixes
everything.  At a certain point you can't take it
anymore and it doesn't always mean a fall.  Sometimes it's
a relief.  Elijah, Moses, David.
In the Bible, even the strong had
moments when they could no longer
bear it all.  Why?
Because God didn't create you to be the
nervous system of a
dysfunctional house.
If every time you return to certain relatives
you feel like you've just finished an emotional marathon,
perhaps you're not the one doing the wrong thing;
perhaps you've stopped playing the part
that kept a false balance afloat.
And there is also a sign that many
ignore.  God sends new people and the
contrast wakes you up.  You meet someone
who speaks to you with respect and
suddenly you realize how
used to harshness you were.  You experience a
clean friendship and then you notice how
toxic that climate was, where love
always arrived with a sting.
[music]
In church, at work, in a
simple conversation with someone who does
n't need to dominate you, [music]
you discover that you don't have to earn the
right to exist.  This is very
powerful because often God enlightens you not
only by showing you the
bad, but by letting you taste the good.  And
when you taste the true good, the
emotional surrogate is no longer enough.
But not everything here is resolved with
dialogue.  I know it's trendy these days to say
talk about it, explain yourself better, communicate
calmly.   It's
fine as long as there's a conscience on the other side
willing to listen, but with
those who manipulate, deny, distort the facts, and
use your openness as material
against you, endless dialogue
becomes self-sabotage.
Even Jesus, faced with certain closures,
remained silent or distanced himself; he did not chase after
everyone, he did not let himself be held back by
everyone.
This idea that a spiritual person
must always remain accessible,
available, reachable, and gentle with
everyone, in my opinion, has done more damage
than we care to admit.
Boundless goodness in the
wrong hands becomes fuel for
abuse.  And this is where a truth comes in
that surprises many.  Leaving
is not always a punishment, sometimes it is a
response.
There are doors that close, arguments
that create distance,
sudden moves, jobs that change,
relationships that cool, and you
initially think everything is broken.
Then, with time, you understand that it was precisely that
detachment that gave you back clarity.
In the Bible Abraham must leave
his father's house to enter his
calling.
Giuseppe is violently separated
from his family and, although very
painful, that separation opens up a
trajectory that he would otherwise
never have seen.  This does not mean
romanticizing pain, but recognizing
that God sometimes saves you even by
defusing closeness.  If this has
happened to you, let me know in the comments.  Perhaps
a distance that at first seemed like a
loss.  over time it proved to be a
protection.  At this point, a piece of advice I
consider valuable is this: stop
measuring the quality of a relationship by its
good moments and start measuring it by
its recurring effects.
Even toxic relationships have
tender parentheses.   This
is precisely what makes them confusing.
A family member can hug you at Christmas and
destroy you in February, [music] can
help you financially and then use
that help as a moral promissory note for
years.
In Italy, this ambiguity is
often seen in families where favors
become control.  I'll give you a hand with the
house, with work, with the children, but
then you owe me access, obedience,
silence, but healthy love doesn't
present you with the bill.  An adult,
almost clinical, criterion is to observe patterns,
not episodes.  If a person alternates between
caressing and dominating, you are not faced with an
innocent contradiction, you are inside a
cycle.  Another piece of advice, more
surprising than it seems, is not to
overexplain your healing to those who
benefit from your injury.
When God takes you out of certain
dynamics, the desire to
finally be understood is born within you.  It's human, but it
's not always wise.  Those who were
often monitoring you don't want to understand you, they just want to
regain access.  This is why the
best boundaries are simple, short, and
repeatable.   We
don't need rants, we need
clean, coherent sentences.   I wo
n't talk about this now, I can't
come today.
If you raise your voice I'll end the
conversation.   It
seems unspiritual, I think the
opposite.  Clarity [music] is a
form of truth, and the truth in the Bible
liberates, does not entrap in
endless negotiations.  Then there is a deeper dimension
that is rarely talked about
[music] enough.
Separating yourself from a toxic environment can
make you feel guilty before it makes you
feel free.   It
's normal.  Guilt is often a
symptom of ancient training, not
proof that you are doing something wrong.  If for
years you've been raised to confuse
love with total availability,
as soon as you draw a boundary you'll feel like you've
become bad.  But you're not
bad, you're unlearning a
distortion.
Paul writes that God has not given us a
spirit of fear, but of power, love
[music] and discipline.
Well, emotional discipline is also
this: not immediately going back to where you were
hurt just because you lack
familiarity.
Not everything that is familiar to you is good for you
.  Sometimes even the cage after
a long time smells of [music] home.  And
I want to tell you something as a woman,
sincerely.  Some family members won't
change just because you finally
cried, prayed, explained,
forgave, waited.  This is one of the
hardest truths to accept, but also
one of the most liberating.  You can
change location, you can change
access, you can change the geography of
your heart.  You can't always change the
[music] of those who have chosen to remain blind.
Authentic faith is not denying reality
to appear good, it is looking it in the
face without losing one's soul.  And in
my opinion, one of the highest forms of spiritual maturity
is to stop asking those who have
always given you crumbs for the bread that only
God and sometimes new people can
offer you.
Ultimately perhaps the clearest sign that
God is distancing you from someone
[music] is that you stop calling peace
what was really just the absence
of conflict.
True peace doesn't make you smaller, doesn't
force you to filter every word, doesn't
make you live on high alert as if you had to
foresee the next outburst, the
next fault, the next
elegant humiliation delivered with a smile.
True peace gives you back breathing space,
presence, the ability to pray without
feeling dirty, clarity in saying yes, and
dignity in saying no.  If this message
touched you, tell me in the comments
when you first
realized that putting [music] away
wasn't betraying your family, but rather stopping
betraying yourself.
And if you want to continue this journey with
us, sign up for Dose Mentale.  Here we
are never looking for comfortable phrases,
but we seek truths that truly heal you
.  See you in the next one